thank you
[Music]
all right so uh this was submitted by
A.G uh there's a thing that just came
out from the FDA where uh remember like
the foods that we grew up thinking they
were healthy because of the pyramid oh
yeah oh yeah that was wrong messing up
and changing them oh cool so really yeah
so we're like all right that was the
milk industry I'm sorry sorry
sugary cereals and white bread are now
not being considered healthy good I
think they're wrong I think it's pretty
healthy I feel pretty great shut your
[__] mouth you know what they're
talking about I think when I start my
day with a bowl of Frosted Flakes if
you're in white bread I feel Cinnamon
Toast Crunch I haven't had white bread
in a while
but I do like a bowl of cereal it was
very strange I think as a kid being like
Cookie Crisp like this is healthy yes
cookies
it's children's the sugary here the
better I never thought it was for kids
bruh but like they used to talk like on
commercials even as a kid I would hear
the commercials and I'm like you guys
are [__] trippy yeah that's what I
thought too like this [__]
six-year-old you guys are tripping dude
you don't think you knew yeah you didn't
like that I'm like low is my cholesterol
dad come on you know I just knew if it
tasted like [__] it was probably good
for you yeah it's probably good for me
but it's nasty as [__] I know this is
random dude this is random but you know
my pet peeve with every commercial we
were growing up but was it they would at
the end shot they're like part of a
complete breakfast and had a oh yeah the
[__] oh oatmeal I was like yeah [__]
the cereal get that [__] the cereal dude
that was in it yeah dude I have a
grapefruiter like dude and I hated like
the shows like a Disney every Disney
show every Disney Channel the dad would
come in and they would never eat the
breakfast it would have pissed me the
[__] off
[Laughter]
dude they never seem rushed but they're
late but they never seen words like yeah
yeah no I got a big test today
bro you were so [__] calm like if
you're late you know you're [__] dude
[__] what's up what's up what's up
what's up hurry here speeding up speed
it up yeah you're not trying to have
conversations and then the pancake stack
was so high
so high it makes that much pancakes at
home [__] it's like for the whole day
every family that I know they make it
fresh as they go because if you stack it
up this high that [__] gets cold yes
[__] body that does it that way yeah
what's crazy when you go to those old
school Diners right they actually have
the distinction like full stack or stack
right yeah the short stack is already at
least three pancakes I'm like who the
[__] is eating this the rock yeah the
rocket [__]
who the [__] eats like eight pancakes
like that's like they wake up and they
need eight pancakes Tommy the truck
drivers oh yeah here for the [__]
he falls asleep while he's dry yeah dude
hello but I could eat like two pancakes
tops and by the way I was always as a
kid team pancake but as an adult I've
kind of switched over team waffles
waffle is a great way to go
bad taste man
I'm sorry I love French I like a thin
pancake the waffle is good because it
has a little like pocket of syrup just
yeah if it's crispy just a little bit of
crisp a little bit yeah it's nice to
have the syrup collected that is nice
yeah anyways but it is kind of weird
though that we eat dessert for breakfast
I love it we're eating a [__] wedding
cake for breakfast think about that's
the same reason why Donald it's not a
wedding cake it's a waffle yeah dude
either a berry Danish goddamn goddamn
Dunkin Donuts failed in India because of
that why because they're like why would
I want this because in in India they
don't eat sugar for breakfast so they
were like why are all these things here
like who's gonna eat or when you go to
IHOP you have to pull out of India where
they go to IHOP and then they have to
like upsell pancakes so they go we're
gonna get a strawberry cheesecake oh my
God and you're like what the Fruity
Tooty fresh and fruity oh did you guys
ever have did you guys ever have Eggo
waffles yeah what's that it was called
waffle where there was stuff in it oh
chips
oh you ever got that no I did not
absolutely awesome I had the blueberry
one so good I love angle waffles my mom
never let me buy those I didn't get the
one that was stuck yeah I had like
different things in it like you could
get uh like chocolate different what
about a toaster strudel oh those were
good
they let us put the icing
and you could make a design like you
would [__] draw a rabbit didn't you
feel like you had those hats
you got the little corner just looking
yeah Joe's just poking holes in it
[__] on the inside yeah your dad's
taking it your dad's taking you to the
[__] school you're just like hey he's
got the [__] speed bumps like hey
I'm a chef over a piece over here don't
wait at school yeah
you guys always put them in the toaster
and you just eat them always in the
toaster dude you look at the one you
never ate them on the go like
when I was an adult I had it cold and I
was like damn this is really I prefer a
toaster it has to be toasted cold was
still
banging yeah to me that's like eating
cookie dough oh it's raw yeah it has to
be toasted you know it was a bomb
breakfast when we ran out of cereal I
would get [__] cookies crumble it up
and then put it in a bowl of milk that's
pretty good too yeah chips a whole same
[__] basically whoa dude whoa I gotta
take a step back on that one dude that's
way higher fast
excuse for a cereal was Oreos okay
it was good though it's whole grades
dude it's really good but that's like so
that's a cereal it's chocolate whole
grains bro it's crazy [__] fast [__]
though we're just eating like sugar bars
and cardboard that's like that's like
500 calories right there this is pups
y'all remember [__] Sara Lee pound
cake oh my God oh my God the one that's
in the freezer yeah
sneak away pound cake is always going to
be it's so good like we're gonna get a
butter knife oh sometimes you would you
would take pound cake and you would take
it to go do you put in a paper towel
right and you take the paper towel off
it just covered in boiled it oh that's
my favorite oh it's so good but they're
delicious that's how you make a paper
towel edible
paper towel done have you guys ever had
a coffee cake yeah yeah dude you know
the top of that [__] is all just
cinnamon and sugar yeah but it's like a
whole layer of just let me just get
sugar and put it on top it's crust it's
thickness of Happiness dude yeah for
lunch right now
I totally sidetracked the [__] out of it
let's be healthy let's go to the house
let's start nutritional American like
that's what our breakfast was right
there yeah dude it's just stuck to the
bottom because that's how fresh it was
dude [__] donuts and coffee what else
is unhealthy dude so they are hard they
are replacing them with things that are
healthy like a [__] carrot
they're adding avocados and salmon okay
yeah I'll take that okay
totally new Millennia already you know
what I mean 28 first you know you know
um this is my big avocado dude I don't
like it
is there a shortage on like is there
like a big amount of [__] avocados
and salmon that's what they're doing
this there aren't like America's known
to do [__] like this there is a
competitively big amount of avocados
really and the way that's going on will
not we'll regionally California because
the cartel makes it too now oh yeah good
for them but they are very healthy
that's true delicious I love them
avocados are the best if you open the
avocado see that's where all the cocaine
is
hello so they're all sure I love avocado
in addition to all this is uh they've
also approved lab meat for human
consumption
it's really bad possible me yeah all
that [__] is really really bad so it's
meat that you can eat that wasn't due to
the sacrifice of an animal it's meat
that's located in a lab based on the
cells of a cow or something they're
saying don't eat synthetic meat look at
this and they'll just make do all this
science [__] and then before you know
you got T-bone steak have you ever had
any possible stuff so imagine carne
asada out of [__] lab mean imagine
don't talk to me like that dude so did
you talk to a Mexican like that dude no
no real meat yeah what do you feel like
what do you feel like the difference is
between the impossible taste to like
regular beef no but he's not talking
about impossible it's possible is vegan
so he's talking about lab growth it's
not the same no no don't get mad at me
dude what [__] chemicals and [__]
he's out of a petri dish have you had
lab grow meat before and you guys no no
I did wait is beyond me that no Beyond
this like beans I had impossible that's
vegan stuff no those those are you like
meat where do you get the lab girl where
can we get it there's a scientists not
to market right not yet guys this is
like Powerpuff girls [__] Dad yeah
and he creates a [__] T-bone steak
out of like just chemicals no thank you
you know what's funny no thank you my
guy about you know what's [__] up
about this [__] though is people take
this stuff and believe it right so
there's so many people that don't know
what just health is and then that idea
of Health too it's all [__] up right
now because you have people who are
obese that are straight up saying like
I'm fully healthy yeah oh like lizzo I
swear to God nothing makes me more
[__] angry than Liz those [__]
post let me tell you something wait
didn't she get canceled for losing
weight
people get mad for trying to lose weight
yeah you're like fat phobic [__] you
didn't even lose weight right now I like
lizzo okay what are you gonna say dude
let me say high cholesterol I still like
her she wears these revealing ass
clothes that I'm just like girl uh let
me tell you something I'm sick and tired
of seeing this [__] and she's just
acting like like this is a normal body
like [__] for who like this is not
healthy this is not like I don't you
know what I mean like let's just keep it
real let's keep it 100 like this is not
she's like I get what she's doing I
understand we haven't been keeping it
real for the last five years you know
it's mentally healthy yeah we haven't
been real in a long time you guys
haven't been ruined a minute no it's
just the America oh we haven't kept it
real then keep it 100. but also like
blame like FDA government all them for
not teaching people and that's why so
many people got fat yeah because it's
like dude we're eating [__] sugar for
breakfast and they're calling that
healthy of course everyone's gonna be
fat but you know what though FDA they
don't have good socials bro they're not
on Instagram making posts about me yeah
dude like no one yeah that's where
people are getting their their dude
liver King is way higher than [__]
FDA you know what I mean and he was
right with steroids FDA make yourself
bro watch your mouth I bet you when you
guys are training people or whatever
right there's so many people that still
don't know [__] about food and normal
[__] a lot of re-education is so weird
that FDA never had a poster boy that's
like oh I'm I look like this and I eat
everything the FDA says yeah if they
signed the rock yeah people would I
would buy three of those pyramids put on
my [__] wall
you want to look like that guy yeah and
[__] the Rocks three of them but he's
got the [__] you know the the [__]
throwing the people's elbow on [__]
junk food and [__] [__] people healthy
is kind of simple right it doubles up on
the junk food bro I I know someone that
thinks that chicken nuggets is the same
thing as a chicken strip
isn't it real chicken now because we
love McDonald's and we want we want to
get sponsored by McDonald's chicken
tenders are delicious
dinosaur chicken nuggets like dinosaurs
nuggets oh yeah dinosaurs
yeah but it's like a grilled chicken leg
like come on like there's like oh they
think there's no difference at all not
that much wow dude if a kid is eating
dino nuggets they're happy true dumb
right they got they mama is
they taught us how to read the nutrition
facts 100 because technically all food
comes in nutrition facts yeah but none
of us are reading it nobody ever looks
out yeah a lot of people don't those
words mean as kids because other people
can tell the difference between dino
nuggets Nitro glycerin acid what yeah
phosphoric but at the same time there's
a big interest for corporations to just
sell us all these like that's what the
whole thing was based on yeah like for
instance like Doritos dude there's
[__] lab scientists making sure that
every chip is like the most delicious
and it is it really is we'll buy the
food that you could ever eat so then
when you eat like veggies or like you
said chicken breasts it's like this
doesn't taste the same chicken it's like
people don't teach us how to eat so then
it's really hard for us to like navigate
our life trying to figure out what to be
My Philosophy is like you should do
cocaine with the with the knowledge of
what it's going to do to you right
versus like doing it every day thinking
that it's good for you yeah that's also
true yeah definitely true know but that
made sense
I don't know how you did that